après 19 ans de service il a quitté son
poste de directeur de cabinet le 31
décembre dernier pour se lancer
pleinement dans cette campagne
laurens merckaert conduit la liste
montigny ensemble issu de la majorité
sortante
nous avons l'intention bien sûr de
préserver ce à quoi les gens sont très
attachés dans la ville c'est à dire un
cadre de vie privilégié des services
extrêmement important et aussi dans la
relation qu'il peut y avoir entre les
habitants et leurs élus une connexion
permanente transition écologique
sécurité une réhabilitation du centre
ville imaginée avec les habitants sont
les grandes lignes du programme qui sera
dévoilé fin février avec les 39 nom de
la liste un groupe montigné ensemble qui
sera renouvelée à 50 %
on peut parler de continuité créatrice
voilà c'est à dire continuer à
travailler
comme on l'a toujours fait mais essayer
de faire en sorte aussi d'y apporter
tous les changements que nous estimons
nécessaire et ce toujours en étroite
collaboration avec nos habitants lorrain
merckaert se présente sans étiquette
mais de sensibilité centriste au sein
d'un groupe ouvert
je n'ai pas sollicité de soutien en
revanche si les parties souhaitent des
partis républicains bien sûr souhaite
m'apporter leur leur soutien je le
prendrai avec plaisir et évidemment je
le ferais figurer sur la fiche je pense
qu'il faut être dire les choses comme
elles sont vis-à-vis des habitants
première réunion publique pour cette
liste le 15 janvier à la salle
jacques-brel lésigny montants ont déjà
commencé à recevoir le courrier deux
candidatures dans leur boîte aux lettres
les tractages commenceront le premier
week end de février